50 years ago external hard drives were
the size of refrigerators today they
squeeze a lot more memory into drives
the size of chocolate bars
on the hard drive assembly line there's
not a speck of dust an air filtering
system sucks particles out of the air to
keep them from contaminating the drive
and compromising its function
production starts with the motor base an
employee installs a voice coil magnet
it's one of two that will move the drive
heads to write information on rotating
discs they're called voice coils because
they operate on the same Principle as
loudspeakers
next a robot places one of the hard
drive discs in the motor base
a camera snaps a photo to send
information to guide the robot so it
positions the disc exactly
another robot places around metal spacer
at the center of the disk again relying
on the camera's eye for guidance
it sets a second disc on top of the
spacer
this is a two-disc hard drive but a
drive can have several depending on the
amount of storage needed
a robot locks the discs into place with
a stainless steel clamp
this next part is a plastic ramp
the ramp is a place to park the disk
drive heads when they're not engaged in
reading and writing data
[Music]
those tiny heads have been pre-assembled
to one end of the head arm
they attach the other end of the arm to
the lower voice coil in the base and
then situate the second voice coil above
it
foreign
to maintain its squeaky clean interior a
robot inserts a thin cotton filter
this filter will capture dust particles
in the event that some infiltrate the
hard drive
a robot now places a metal cover on the
other side of the drive
[Music]
another robot then screws the cover to
the motor base
[Music]
with the inner workings now encased the
hard drive can be moved out of the air
filtered section of the factory
a worker collects the hard drive
assemblies and Slots them into a Tote
box
once a circuit board has been added they
transfer the hard drives to a test
chamber
behind the closed door of the chamber a
robot swings into action
it plucks a hard drive from The Tote box
and plugs it into a test cell to confirm
that it's functional
outside employees go about their daily
business as the robot methodically tests
each hard drive in the tote boxes
once a tote of drives is confirmed to be
operational the chamber ejects them and
a worker then does a visual inspection
of each one
she looks for scratches or other damage
that could hinder its function
there's another slightly different
system for testing in this one the
employee places each drive on a conveyor
that delivers it to a robot tester
having two tester systems ensures that
if one goes down they still have another
one to carry on
after all like humans robots are not
infallible
[Music]
at the packing station now there's one
last visual inspection the employee
scans the drive serial number so its
production can be traced in the event of
a problem later
she then seals it in plastic
[Music]
this hard drive is now ready to accept
data and ensure that someone doesn't
totally lose it if their computer drive
crashes
foreign